bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir et si c'était tel la
grande gagnante des élections
législatives avec une très forte
progression en nombre de voix marine le
pen réalise le meilleur score de
l'histoire du rassemblement national à
cette élection performance historique
donc le rn qui s'installe dans de
nouvelles terres de conquête on va y
revenir mais qui risquent à nouveau de
se heurter à un plafond de verre au
second tour grand décryptage dans un
instant avec nos invités sur ce plateau
dix ans dix ans à l'assemblée balayé en
quelques minutes notre grand témoin ce
soir tire sa révérence au palais bourbon
il vient de faire ses cartons battu
dimanche dernier dans le vaucluse malgré
son ancrage local comment voit-il la
recomposition politique en cours de coin
son échec est il le nom julien aubert
est avec nous ce soir enfin nous
retrouverons nos a franchi pour leur
parti-pris nouvelles accusations dans la
sphère abad ce sera dans le carnet de
campagne dès l'amont dingue à bâle
ministre battu aux législatives une
vieille histoire signée brandon ouaret
et puis tu y ait ou pas tu y être pour
richard wehrli si le président y va
c'est déjà trop tard voilà pour le menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
et
bienvenue à vous chers téléspectateurs
merci d'être au rendez-vous bonsoir
julien aubert bonsoir et merci d'être là
parce que c'est pas si fréquent quand on
vient de perdre à une élection de venir
en parler sur un plateau de télévision
vous avez passé je le disais dix ans à
l'assemblée sur les bancs des
républicains ici au palais bourbon
extrêmement ancré dans cette cinquième
circonscription de vaucluse mais ça n'a
pas suffi on y reviendra vous nous direz
un petit peu la lecture que vous faites
de ces législatives et le rôle que vous
souhaitez jouer à l'avenir et puis le
rôle que vous souhaiter pour votre
famille politique pour la droite dans
l'est dans les quelques semaines qui
viennent après après cette élection
plein d'enjeux pleine de suspense mais
d'abord on va s'arrêter sur un parti que
vous connaissez bien puisque vous le
combat tu es sur le terrain c'est le
rassemblement national
second tour nous offre la possibilité
d'envoyer un groupe très important de
députés patriotes dans la nouvelle
assemblée nationale nous pouvons en
effet espérer nombre de députés pour
faire valoir avec coeur et conviction
vos idées vos valeurs et vos intérêts
voilà marine le pen le soir des
législatives
rarement son parti n a pu nourrir autant
d'espoirs avec des limites on va y
revenir dans le détail ce soir avec vous
béatrice giblin bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes géographe
directrice de la revue de géopolitique
hérodote on a besoin de votre expertise
pour comprendre comment le n réussi
élection après élection dans des terres
nouvelles comme le sud ouest on va en
parler dans un instant bonsoir hervé le
bras on soin ravis de vous accueillir à
nouveau sur ce bateau démographe et
historien chercheur a lui échoué cesse
de nouveaux ouvrages suis sûr que ça va
vous intéresser tiens julien aubert
legrand enfumage populisme et
immigration dans sept pays européens
c'est aux éditions de l'aube avec la
fondation jean jaurès et puis il n'y a
pas de grand remplacement c'est le
géographe et le démographe surtout qui
parle c'est chez grasset bonsoir
philippe olivier est ce que vous êtes
avec nous bienvenue depuis bruxelles
merci d'avoir accepté ce duplex vous
êtes stratège et bras droit de marine le
pen le stratège de rassemblement
national eurodéputés rn à bruxelles je
vais vous donner la parole dans un
instant mais ont d'abord on va regarder
les cartes on va regarder les résultats
si j'ai bien compris mon camarade
stéphane blakowski pour ouvrir le bal
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bonsoir à toutes et à
tous si j'ai bien compris ce soir si
j'ai bien compris myriam en 2027 donc à
la prochaine présidentielle marine le
pen aura 60 ans il ya d'une part n'est
pas très âgé et d'autre part on se
souvient qu'elle avait fait plus de 30 %
second tour en 2007 plus de 40% second
tour en 2022 et donc forcément en 2027
on dit qu'elle pourrait faire plus de
50% quel rapport on parle des légistes
éthique ce soir je suis hors sujet le
bac c'est ça eh ben c'est jordan barre
des lacs va falloir dire ça puisque
c'est lui qui vous a remarqué que le rnd
comme bien parti pour obtenir plus de 15
députés ce qui lui donne un très bon
d'avoir un groupe parlementaire dont la
présidente serait marine le pen est donc
pour lui ben ça serait ce groupe
parlementaire un excellent tremplin pour
2027 en l'écoutent notre objectif en
cinq ans dans les cinq prochaines années
pour préparer déjà la victoire en 2027
et de faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus
aucun français qui nous perçoivent au
travers de la caricature que certains
longtemps on entend fait de nous ah oui
c'est vrai qu'avec un groupe
parlementaire puissant l'assemblée ça
nous aiderait bon en attendant à l'issue
de ce premier tour c'est pas le rn qui
arrive en tête ces ensembles coalition
présidentielle et la nuque et vous
pouvez même rajouté qu en nombre de
sièges selon les projections les arènes
devrait même être derrière les
républicains mais est ce que disent les
sondeurs que les photos ce n'est qu'une
photo un mouvement ont saisi un moment
sur l'instantané mais ce qui compte
c'est la dynamique annick au fait ça
veut dire est ce que ta partie est en
train de gagner des lecteurs ou sk parti
est en train d'en perdre donc je vous
pose regarder une carte il faut
s'attacher aux circonscriptions qui sont
en en bleu marine en 2017 voyez c'était
celle où le fn était arrivé en tête
étaient assez peu nombreuses regardez
comme elles sont devenues nombreuses en
2022 ça ça s'appelle une bonne dynamique
donc on voit même kelly région ou à
l'ouest dans l'aquitaine elle n'était
pas du tout présent maintenant regarder
la une de sud ouest cette semaine qui
vous a remarqué ben voilà qui avaient
des députés qui avaient des chances
d'être
élu à l'assemblée va bien alors et de
blaye à combien alors ça c'est une
question qu'on pose souvent à marine le
pen mais vous savez qu elle s'embrouille
parfois avec les chiffres est là donc
c'est pas très claire sur ces chiffres
elle a fait des têtes déclaration à ce
sujet je vous laisse les basses et un
peu en vue à un moment elle pensait que
l'heure est sans doute une visait
apparemment une dizaine de députés
ensuite elle s'est mis à dire plutôt au
dessus de 60 ans un moment elle même cru
que ça serait la centaine dont je veux
dire à la fin ce qui compte c'est
qu'elle est minimum
15 députés pour avoir donc ce fameux
groupe et lui après c'est du bonus mais
ça a une influence aussi sur remplir des
caisses du parti vous savez que ils ont
une dette d'une vingtaine de millions
plus de 20 millions et rennes donc là
avec plus de 4 millions de bouakal
obtenu il ya déjà une première dotation
qui sera autour de 7 millions par an qui
vont tenter vont bénéficier puis ensuite
fui en brousse et les chiffres de la
dernière mandature 37000 euros par
députés supplémentaires pour le rn donc
si l'on 25 députés ça fera un petit
millions de plus donc je résume vie
médian par an pendant cinq ans ça fait
quarante millions pour la mandature x
les problèmes de financiers d'une marine
le pen devrait être là derrière elle
alors en attendant c'est c'est pas le
premier groupe d'opposition d'après
d'après les sondages ça restaurer la
nuque enfin avec prudence mais
certainement il ya quand même chose
c'est que non seulement mélenchon ne
sera pas élu à matignon mais en plus il
fera pas non plus élu député ce qui fait
que à l'assemblée marine le pen elle
bénéficierait de la tribune alors que
mélenchon n'y sera pas ensuite il faut
savoir combien de temps la nuit baisse
va rester unie parce qu'il est quand
même des sujets où par exemple sur le
nucléaire il semblerait que fanny
roussel ils sont quand même plus proche
de macron que de mélenchon d'ailleurs
elisabeth bornes elle a appelé à voter
fabien ruf est dans la circonscription
du nord où il affronte au second tour un
élu du rassemblement national mais ça
c'est aussi un argument pour marine le
pen l'iba voyaient ils arrivent à
s'entendre mélenchon aimé et et macro
ont donc mélenchon c'est un opposant en
carton
monsieur jean luc mélenchon qui se dit
aujourd'hui opposant emmanuel macron a
contribué à le faire élire si jean luc
mélenchon si le responsable du parti
socialiste et le responsable des verts
n'avait pas rappelé votez manuel mâcon
au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle il n'aurait pas été élu
et juste pour conclure je vous rappeler
que marine le pen a fait plus de 70 % au
second tour à la guadeloupe et que là
d'ailleurs législatives il a 5 6% je le
répète parce que là on est un de ces
candidats qui est qualifié et en tête en
fait pour le sus du premier tour donc
c'est la dédiabolisation aussi continue
parce que là évidemment ça va devenir de
plus en plus compliqué d'expliquer qu'il
ya que les petits blancs racistes qui
votent pour marine le pen donc je pense
matière à débat et je vous laisse merci
merci pour ce billet merci stéphane je
vais commencer par vous philippe olivier
on a beaucoup dit marine le pen qu'elle
était très discrète dans cette campagne
des législatives
qu'elle pouvait manquer d'ambition en
tout cas laisser vraiment le champ libre
à jean luc mélenchon et à ça et à sa
coalition de gauche qui affiche de deux
grands objectifs est ce que au fond au
regard de ce premier tour vous trouvez
votre stratégie payante ou vous
regrettez de ne pas avoir été un peu
plus présent on veut des plutôt bon
score quand vous avez fait vous aurez pu
faire mieux
pas du tout nous avons l'habitude de ne
pas mentir aux électeurs
nous nous refusons de raconter n'importe
quoi monsieur mélenchon explique qu'il
va être élu premier ministre hors
d'abord on n'est pas élu premier
ministre ensuite il ne risque pas d'être
premier ministre personne ne le croit
que lui et quelques gogos sur des
plateaux de télévision nous nous traçons
notre sillon et si vous avez vu la
présidentielle nous avons créé une
campagne extrêmement sérieuse une
campagne de terrain une campagne où on
n'a pas essayé de faire du du
bling-bling mais de travailler les
problèmes quotidiens de parler de voir
et cela de la sécurité l'immigration et
bien on a été récompensé par les
électeurs parce que marine a été
qualifié au deuxième tour et là de la
même manière de refaire campagne
extrêmement sérieuse sans sans mentir
aux électeurs en leur disant la vérité
sur nos perspectives sur deux objectifs
et nous sommes récompensés avec un score
historique et nous allons concrétiser
cela dit ventre ça avec un grand groupe
si les acteurs
alors j'essaie
dynamique un grand groupe sait combien
de députés c'est vrai qu'en voir votre
progression est spectaculaire un plus
d'un million de voix par rapport à la
législatives d'il ya cinq ans en 2017
mais franchement on se dit que malgré
tout le mode de scrutin reste un
obstacle pour vous combien de députés
espérez-vous
le mode de scrutin il est crapuleux il
doublement crapuleux d'abord parce que
il est objectivement injuste puisque l
air qui a qui a deux fois moins de voix
que nous on va avoir deux certainement
beaucoup plus de députés que nous et
plus de financements publics puisque
vous en parlez donc ça veut dire qu'une
voie du rassemblement national rapporte
moins d'élus et moins de financements
publics moins de possibilité de
s'exprimer mais si vous voulez le groupe
c 15 élus a évidemment tu espères bien
qu on aura quinze élus on aura des
dizaines d'élus savoir combien on en
aura évidemment le sait pas parce qu'il
ya le mode de scrutin et les données
locales globalement
l'objectif serait 60 élus ce qui nous
permet d'avoir une capacité autonome
d'intervention à l'assemblée mais ça
fait que nous avons marine excusez-moi
marine a fait
50% dans 156 cette circonscription donc
on pourrait évidemment éventuellement
dépasser les 100 donc il ya des
perspectives et puis elle est objective
institutionnelle en tout cas merci nous
donner les chiffres 60 élus avec un
objectif on va dire espérer voir rêver à
100 dernière question que je fais
circuler la parole quel autre chose de
leur quel opposant tu veux pas l'être à
l'assemblée nationale elle présidera le
groupe c'est probable qu'il y ait un
groupe et qu'elle soit élue sachant que
jean luc mélenchon ne sera pas dans
l'arène qu'elle opposante politique
veut-elle être dans l'hémicycle alors
nous nous voulons incarner une
opposition qui devrait vous fois ferme
c'est à dire sans condition avec macro
c'est pas le cas le mélenchon qui on le
voit quelques accointances roussel jadot
hidalgo ont appelé à voter macron et et
mélenchon a appelé à s'abstenir et puis
nous voulons être une opposition
républicaine ce que n'est pas monsieur
mélenchon monsieur melanson flirte avec
le séparatisme avec l'indicé nil avec
l'islamisme est hors du champ
républicain et donc nous pensons qu'il
faut une opposition solide mais une
opposition ferme et républicaine je
crois que nous incarnons très très très
aisément merci philippe olivier julien
aubert c'est intéressant d'entendre au
fond un argumentaire en disant on
progresse en voix il ya un mode de
scrutin il est questionné à longueur de
législature mais aucun pouvoir de droite
comme de gauche ni macro ni stsi on dit
pouvoir à centrale n'a osé est touché
même si c'est sans cesse sur le métier
il a peint pour raisons philippe olivier
là quand il dit au fond les républicains
seront peut-être devant nous alors qu'il
faut au moins deux voix l'adjectif cru
crapuleux n'est n'est pas neuilly n'est
pas applicable injuste peut-être ça pue
le il faut faire attention aux mots
c'est vrai que le scrutin majoritaire à
un tour wpt à deux tours des formes la
représentation pour donner une majorité
sont des scrutins qui donnent une
majorité à l'exécutif tous ceux qui
plaident pour la proportionnelle
considère qu'en réalité la
représentativité politique elle passe
par la diversité des partis au parlement
moi je crois qu'elle passe par la
diversité des individus prenez par
exemple en grande-bretagne vous avez
deux parties et pourtant chaque partie à
une grande diversité interne et la
démocratie britannique aurait quelques
quelques leçons à donner la démocratie
française pareille aux états unis en
revanche il ya des three des systèmes
proportionnels où il n'y a pas de
majorité et où c'est l'inefficacité au
pouvoir je pense à l'italie ou à la
belgique donc moi je suis favorable à ce
que ta majorité est effectivement à deux
tours c'est vrai que c'est anormal qu'un
parti comme le rassemblement national
n'est pas si vous voulez plus de députés
il faudrait qu'ils aient un groupe 60
pourquoi 60 députés pour avoir une mère
pour avoir une autonomie c'est sans
doute pour la saisine du conseil
constitutionnel mais à partir de 15 on
peut être autonome on peut avoir je
dirais une visibilité encore foutu
connaissait que c'est une forme
d'exploit je mets des guillemets mais
politique pour un parti qui a un tel
handicap puisqu'il n'a pas d'alliés n'a
aucune réserve à part peut-être les
abstentionnistes que de réussir ce score
là beaucoup d'eau pour cause du bruit au
moins 15 députés ce qui soutenait ça ne
s'est pas produit depuis 1986 on essaie
dont la gt la proportionnelle en fait ce
qui se passe c'est que dans les second
tour c'est l'effet répulsif
et il se trouve que bon d'abord il y
avait personne qu'on présente il ya
quelques jeunes ya quelques
circonscriptions où leur assemblée
nationale a présenté des gens qui
manifestement avait des difficultés sur
les plateaux télévision pour expliquer
ne serait-ce que le programme est
ensuite il ya un effet répulsif et ça
qu'on le veuille ou pas il ya une partie
de bosses je vois même en vous plus une
partie de l'électorat de droite qui ne
veut pas voter si c'est une étiquette
rassemblement national c'est vrai que ça
a tendance à diminuer voilà
malheureusement pendant ce temps là les
problèmes de la france je dirais
continue il donc vous situez peut-être
pour nos téléspectateurs je précise que
vous n'avez pas donné de consigne de
vote dont je n'ai pas de second chez
vous dans le vaucluse c'est
rassemblement national contre contre
ensemble je gagne je nie l'ancienne donc
pas de front républicain non pour vous
ce n'est pas que je suis même ligne que
les régimes hostiles au front
républicain et je vais vous dire le fond
de ma pensée il ya un point que je
partage avec si olivier au moins c'est
que je pense que la france a soumises et
bien moi républicaine sur certains
aspects et notamment sur l'adhésion ou
qu'ils sur le communautarisme d'un
certain type de clientélisme s'est dit
béatrice giblin regardons à nouveau ses
cartes qu'on a vu avec le bleu marine
d'un côté 2017 les voici on va aller
voir sa fille chez moi je les vois sur
mon écran et sont à l'antenne les voilà
on voit quand même que effectivement on
a tout le nord-est une bonne partie du
sud est la corse n'est pas nouveau ça
mais regardons la côte ouest on a la
gironde une partie de la charente le
médoc le lot et garonne
tout ça ce sont deux totalement de
nouvelles terres il n'y avait pas
beaucoup d'électeurs rassemblement
national dans ces terres là qu'est ce
qui s'est passé il ya eu quelque chose
qui s'est appelée gilet jaune d'abord
vous souvenez que autour de bordeaux les
gilets jaunes ont été particulièrement
actif avec des manifestations tous les
samedis qui descendait du médoc
justement parce que dans le vignoble et
est un vote front national depuis
longtemps sauf le vignoble de la loire
mais la champagne était un vote front
national depuis très très longtemps en
bourgogne c'était un vote front national
important avec bd des grands négociants
du bourgogne qui appelait à voter front
national
la dordogne c'est là de la dordogne
c'est plus c'est plus compliqué mais
c'est sûr que ce qui est important dans
cette extension du vote c'est comment
des zones rurales c'est pas forcément
des agriculteurs quand on dit zone
rurale c'est des gens qui habitent dans
la campagne mais qui ont sombré zone
qu'on dit parfois enclavé avec des défis
biloxi même si elles le sont c'est pas
tellement qu'elles ont des difficultés
d'accès mais si vous voulez les densités
sont trop faibles pour y avoir des
transports en commun donc il faut
prendre sa voiture est très souvent s'il
ya deux membres de la famille qui
travaille ça va faire deux voitures et
tout ça coûte évidemment très très cher
et pour se loger si on veut vraiment une
maison avec un bout de jardin quand on
n'a pas un gros capital il faut aller
assez loin pour pouvoir soit récupéré
une ancienne maison rurale qu'on va
bricoler remettent en état donc sa
seizième d'où ses électeurs à la base eh
bien nous y ronde mais les niçois
s'appelait la gauche plutôt
oui pour une part sûrement mais pas tant
que ça parce que ça s'accompagne aussi
d'une grande chute de dudu et l'air
alors le sou des cdt
radical-socialiste cd terre de gauche
depuis très de radicale et centriste oui
mais vous voyez aussi que c'est des
terres sur lequel il faudrait remettre
la carte mélenchon va là encore aussi
très très bien c'est quand même des
terres qui reste très favorable à
mélenchon si vous regardez tout le rouge
regardez tout le sud on va dire du
massif central où une grande partie du
massif central on se rend compte que on
a là quand même une force de l'année
pèse qui est importante rappelle que
c'est une carte où on a mis une couleur
donc rouge pour la nuque une bleu marine
pour le rn en fonction des candidats
arrivés en tête au premier tour des
législatives et législatives mais s'ils
ont regardé la carte des présidentielles
et de ce qui était arrivé en tête dans
au niveau communal ou cantonal aux
présidentielles on aurait ce même rouge
au fond dans l'arrière-pays du littoral
du sud-est ce serait la même chose on
retrouverait exactement la présence de
deux de mélenchon c'était un peu moins
nette dans le cadre du sud du massif
central mais c'est que c'est quand même
assez présent dernière chose moi ce qui
me frappe beaucoup c'est que sur ses
terres socialistes d'une région
industrielle
très forte du nord comme de l'est la
présence de mélenchon est extrêmement
faible et c'est vrai mais là c'est le
rassemblement national or son drama si
je peux me permettre
hervé le bras comment vous vous
expliquer ces phénomènes dans le papier
de sud ouest il ya un loup reportages et
ya pas mal d'électeurs qui disent j'ai
voté ps je vote fn notamment en charente
dans le médoc c'est c'est quand même on
se dit de psa est reine qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pour se méfier parce que là
c'est de céder cartes qu'ils
représentent les législatives ouais mais
si on regarde les cartes de la
présidentielle ou si on regarde je vais
revenir les cartes des départementales
déjà depuis au profond au fond depuis le
premier vote en 1984 pour le pen la
moyenne vallée de la garonne était déjà
particulière et votait déjà pensé
qu'on ne prend que c'est d'eux que ces
deux élections comparaison mais si on
prend même la comparaison actuel de 2022
par rapport à ce que marine le pen a
fait à la présidentielle elle fait le rn
fait moins que ce qu'elle a fait à la
présidentielle et il fait elle fait
moins même que si j'ai pris ce qui
m'intéresse si j'ai pris
les départementales de 2015 comme
référence c'est parce que c'était des
départementales trip artistes il y avait
à peu près à égalité des trois blocs
qu'il y avait et marine le pen à
l'époque enfin le le à l'époque c'était
le front national frisait les 28 % on
l'a oublié ça c'est pas du du 19 % vont
et puis la gauche était à peu près 27 %
et la droite 37% et la droite à 33% et
c'est intéressant parce que ça sert de
modèle à ce qui se passe actuellement
parce que pour les départements table
pour les cantonales
c'est le même régime
c'est à dire il faut 12,5 pour cent des
inscrits il ya quelque 50% d'abstention
quel a été le résultat voyez que les
trois groupes étaient à peu près à
égalité à l'arrivée le front national
sur les 2000 quand on a eu 34 seulement
le la gauche en a eu qui était en tête
on en a eu qu'un peu moins de 800 et la
droite a ramassé le paquet mais au
premier tour il faut beaucoup se méfier
quand on est dans un régime à trois
parties faut beaucoup semé d un report
et particulièrement de la position au
centre alors on va le voir sur le
terrain philippe ballard défi la
majorité horizons dans l'oise à beauvais
alors là on n'est pas dans le sud ouest
c'est une terre où lille est déjà formé
là il est extrêmement fort puisque
l'ancien journaliste de lci est arrivé
avec 35% des suffrages reportage clément
perreault pierre yves devin qu avec
marion becker
c'est un territoire convoité par le
rassemblement national
ces terres agricoles de l'oise ont placé
le candidat d'extrême droite en tête
chili ballard continue de tracts et pour
conserver toutes ses chances on est ici
à bertaucourt voilà 1109 inscrits et
c'est une des communes effectivement où
on a un petit un petit déficit puisque
marine fait 42% et je suis 40 37 % bon
ce n'est pas si mal mais il ya donc 5%
d'écart il ya trois communes dans ce
dans ce cas donc c'est là où aujourd'hui
on va rencontrer les habitants va
tracter il ya dévoilé chercher
absolument
voilà des voix aller chercher et puis
des électeurs peut-être à convaincre cet
après midi là les habitations la chaire
convaincu
bonjour vous le travail de philippe
ballard je suis candidat du
rassemblement abada corse et où est
reconnue alors bon bah
on espère pour les français d'accord
faut y aller dimanche et dimanche il
affrontera la candidate de la majorité
chanèze erban qui compte sur son
implantation locale pour renverser la
tendance et sur le soutien de l'ex
premier ministre
il doit finir
ta des belles lunettes
on est à fond on se mobilise
un soutien très précieux les présidents
du parti horizon de temps de ma compagne
aujourd'hui sur le terrain que pour le
chrétien contre lui et rennes ça existe
encore assez entendu chance j'espère
j'espère en tout cas j'invite l'ensemble
des électeurs à faire front et
l'ensemble aussi des partis politiques à
le faire je suis l'apprécier dd on
candidate qui est enraciné ici qui est
élu local ici qui connaît la réalité de
ce terrain
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit le corps
de son adversaire quelques instants plus
tard voilà le numéro un du rassemblement
national il ya dix minutes dans ce café
pour soutenir la candidate qui est passé
monsieur valeur et porté la voix du
front républicain quel est votre
réaction
c'est extrêmement un gars comme manière
de faire de la politique
je pense que le front républicain est
justement de voter pour rassemblement
national dimanche une circonscription
décidément très convoité est scruté par
les états-majors du rassemblement
national et de la majorité voilà
philippe olivier elle et elle est très
regardé par les états-majors à sept
circonscriptions elle est centrale pour
vous
écouter il ya 577 circonscriptions nous
on en a 200 8 dans lequel nous sommes
présents ses 208 son central pour nous
et nos électeurs doivent se dire que ils
doivent se mobiliser parce que nous
pouvons réussir
quelque chose de formidable
toutes les circonscriptions sont
importants en même temps on a beaucoup
parlé mode de scrutin vous l'avait
qualifié de crapuleux c'est un gros
obstacle comment vous allez faire quel
est le message précis que vous envoyer
aux abstentionnistes qui sont souvent
plus important que pour d'autres dans
vos rangs parmi vos électeurs
écoutez s'ils ne votent pas on rentrera
dans le tunnel ma chronique pour cinq
ans car il n'y aura pas d'élection il y
aura les élections européennes et qui
sont d'élections un peu particulière il
n'y aura plus d'élection pour cinq ans
et donc monsieur macron s'il a la
majorité absolue pourra faire ce qu'il
veut il faut un groupe important de
députés à l'assemblée nationale pour
porter des thèmes essentiels qui chinon
disparaîtront du débat public
les calibration l'insécurité le pouvoir
d'achat qu'on a qu'on a mis au coeur de
cette campagne électorale et puis la
place de la france il y a un certain
nombre et puis la puissance française
d'énergie le nucléaire etc ce sont des
thèmes sur lequel nous sommes et ce sont
des quais ce sont des thèmes qu'il faut
défendre à l'assemblée nationale parce
que c'est important pour le quotidien et
le régalien ya un nom qu'on n'a pas
prononcé encore depuis le début de ce
débat c'est celui d'eric zemmour
avec le recul la stratégie était la
bonne vous l'avez peut-être tué
politiquement dans sa circonscription
mais une alliance de premier tour aurait
été peut-être plus intelligente en
termes d'objectifs d'élus
écoutez je pense que nous ne l'avons pas
tuer il s'est tué politiquement nous
avons essayé de lui expliquer que sid
revenir au front national des années 80
ans dans les méthodes que dans la
radicalité du diagnostic n'était pas une
un service à rendre à notre famille
politique c'est eu une formidable
régression et n'a pas voulu le
comprendre il a eu un échec aux
présidentielles est un échec aux
législatives
donc nous nous avons décidé de partir
sous nos couleurs parce que il y avait
avec eric zemmour un certain nombre de
divergences et notamment
économiques et sociales faut savoir que
d'un point de vue social le le le
programme d'eric zemmour était très
proche de celui de monsieur macro merci
merci philippe olivier julien ben on va
parler des consignes de vote parce que
ça va être un vrai sujet un cet entre
deux tours il ya énormément de duels
entre les arènes et la nuque mais
d'abord j'aimerais avoir votre regard à
la fois d'anciens élus mais mes deux
voilà d'experts de la politique future
ancien des deux ils sont comment les
rassemblements nationaux sur le terrain
est ce que ce sont devenus des
professionnels de la politique
est ce que il ya des fédérations est ce
que le parti s'est professionnalisé
notamment dans votre région alors moi je
peux parler du vaucluse on va dire que
c'est assez différent vous avez des vous
avez des élus vous avez une génération
d'élus qui est née il ya peut-être une
dizaine d'années avec des profils qui
sont sociologiquement pas ceux du
département mais qui sont des gens qui
ont fait plus effectivement des études
qui s'implantent qui certains
travaillent alors que la génération
d'avant était une génération des fois on
avait on a vu des types qui avait été un
peu et lui un peu par hasard qu'ils
n'avaient rien fait puis quelques
quelques communes après la fédération
rennes chez moi était quand même
durement impactée par le phénomène eric
zemmour le vaucluse on sait bien la
présence de marion maréchal-le pen qui
avait basculé côté zemmour donc ça a
provoqué je dirais un certain nombre de
turpitudes vous en avez aussi un peu
fait les frais si je peux me permettre
parce qu'il ya une division au fond
d'une droite entre l'extrême droite la
droite de zemmour patriotes et une
droite
pour un mouvement qui s'appelle
reconquête
envoyer des candidats contre des
candidats de droite
vous ne faites aucune reconquête facile
idée c'est de reconquérir des terres qui
sont pas à droite en présentant des
candidats j'en suis un bon exemple
eghezée moore a présenté un candidat
contre moi après c'est la démocratie
c'est peut-être effectivement ce qu'ils
cherchaient pas facile mais n'avait
candidats macron il aura donné un un
député de macron de plus au président un
public est très sibyllin les électeurs
ça y est votre rassemblement national
par adhésion oui pour le pouvoir d'achat
sur pour un des plus durs j'ai de la
colère vient aussi simple mais là
n'empêche pas l'autre on a le droit on
peut parfaitement voter pour des raisons
de défense de pouvoir d'achat et aussi
parce qu'on trouve que on sait pas assez
occupé de vous que on peut pas vivre
avec des salaires à 1200 à 1500 euros
dont la laddh là la grande jedir
stratégie payante de marine le pen c'est
qu'en septembre 2021 elle a attaqué sa
campagne électorale très tôt sur le
thème du pouvoir d'achat et pas du tout
sûr celui de l'immigration et de
l'insécurité elle a compris le pays elle
a compris mais pourquoi aussi parce que
c'est vrai qu'elle est au contact
beaucoup plus que zemmour des
difficultés de vie d'une ou certaines
d'un grand nombre de français le fait
d'être élu vous savez au coeur du bassin
minier du pas-de-calais lui fait
effectivement toucher du doigt les très
très grande difficulté
qui marque encore
malgré tous les efforts qu'on peut être
fait parce que faut pas dire qu'on n'a
rien fait mais elle elle le sent très
bien et elle sait
incontestablement leur parler alors on
va parler des consignes de vote c'est
sûr que dans les duels rn ensemble il va
y avoir un petit sujet pourrait rennes
qui n'a pas de report de voix et on
imagine que les républicains vont
d'abord se reporter sur le candidat
macro nice mais dans les duels rm nuque
on a vu toute la semaine les hésitations
du gouvernement sur la la consigne la
stratégie à tenir alors on est allé dans
la 5e circonscription de l'aisne où le
candidat est reine est arrivée largement
en tête face à la coalition de gauche et
puis il ya deux candidats un marcheur
divisée dans cette élection marque au
pommier avec antoine coûte un levier dit
betty et l'analyse d'un vélo bras juste
après
jour de marché à frère en tardenois dans
cette cinquième circonscription de
l'aisne les électeurs macro nist
détiennent les clés du scrutin mais face
au duel et rennes nuque du second tour
ils sont un peu déboussolés ne plaisent
pas dire gagner ou tout simplement
donc je veux pas d'extrême donc je pense
que ce sera ou un blanc ou annuler voter
blanc c'est aussi le choix provisoire
dan en pleine discussion avec jocelyn de
signy candidat du rassemblement national
arrivé largement en tête du premier tour
avec 35% des suffrages quoi vous
n'arrivez pas à choisir madan entre la
nuit et le rassemblement national parce
que je ne choisirait pas entre eux est
ce que vous préférez de la crotte de
chat à manger dans notre assiette de la
crotte de chien qu'est ce que vous
préférez rien nous invite en attendant à
prendre connaissance du programme sur le
site rassemblant nationale oui quand
même on ne pas facile de convaincre mais
jocelyn de signy veut aller chercher
tous les électeurs même ceux d' emmanuel
macron sa stratégie taper sur jean luc
mélenchon les électeurs ne sont pas
dupes ils ont entendu ils connaissent
les propositions de jean-luc mélenchon à
quelqu'un qui est qui qui dit à la télé
que la police tue qui explique aux
patrons c'est eux qui vont porter à 100
qu'on sent le poids de l'augmentation du
smic le plus républicain d2 entre
mariner
il n'y a pas de toutes ces m'arrive donc
s'il doit y avoir un front républicain
j'invite tous les républicains a sonné
vers ma candidature un front républicain
vers lequel se tournent aussi stéphane
frères loin de la figure de jean luc
mélenchon le candidat de la nuque se
présente comme un candidat moins
radicale dimanche il accusait un retard
de 16 points sur son concurrent alors
pour gagner il espère que les électeurs
macro nist fasse la différence entre le
rassemblement national et l'union de la
gauche il y aura ce ce front républicain
qui valent qui va se mettre en place
naturellement tout seul je pense que on
a des électeurs lucide qui savent faire
la différence et qui savent aussi se
dégageait un petit peu de ce que peuvent
lancer les
les mercredis 7 et je pense que
j'ai confiance dans cette intelligence
collective pour voir en tout cas gagné
dans cette circonscription le front
républicain profite plutôt à la nuque
les deux candidats qui se revendiquait
de la majorité présidentielle ont appelé
à voter pour stéphane frère
hervé le bras un front républicain dans
des duels rn19 favorise la nuque
forcément oui enfin c'est ce qui s'est
produit
vers l année on comprend même signer
mais dont justement dans les majeures le
cas que je citais qui est un sert de
modèle grosso modo 30 % des électeurs de
droite et est allée vers le fn de
l'époque et sur le reste il était allé
d'autant plus vers la gauche que l'écart
était plus faible entre c'est à dire ils
ont joué sur l'écart entre la gauche et
puis le fn est donc ça a favorisé très
nettement la la gauche donc je pense que
c'est sans doute ce qui va se se
reproduire et ça va se reproduire
d'autant plus fortement que ya une
caractéristique qui est en train de
changer au fond la guadeloupe est un cas
extrême et le fn un vote qui est de plus
en plus dans les petites communes et
dans les communes rurales qu'on fait une
courbe selon la taille des communes le
fn au dessous de 1000 habitants il est
donc pour toute la france il est à plus
de 30% puis ça descend il n'est plus
qu'à 12 % je parle à la présidentielle
il premier tour il est plus qu à 12%
au-dessus de 100 mille habitants et il
tombe à 6 % et demi pour cent à paris et
nous fait exactement l'inversé d'hier
nut's commença à moins de 15% dans les
petites communes et puis en voyage et la
courbe je pourrais vous pour vous ce
sont des électorats très distincts ces
deux électorats distincts et surtout
mute est en train de progresser au fond
et en train des cartes et le pen vers ce
qui est de plus en plus loin des grands
centres et notamment au fond je suis pas
étonné pour cette histoire des dom tom
c'est un peu on a l'impression que de
plus en plus
le rl est acculé c'est à dire qu'il
aimait rivier avant 2 avant de conclure
ce débat j'aimerais avoir votre
sentiment sur la position du
gouvernement qu'on a vu un peu flottante
sur c'est sur ces consignes de vote rn
nuque ce qu'on comprend c'est qu'en gros
il faut plutôt favorisé la nuque quand
elle n'est pas soumise si j'ai bien
compris un oui et puis comme ça ils
auront macro aura une opposition qui
prônera la haine de la police la haine
sociale et l'agitation de rue je pense
que les électeurs ma chronique qui ne
sont pas idiots on se rende compte que
de promouvoir la nuit baisse c'est une
c'est une aberration républicaine c'est
un danger mortel pour le pays ce sont
des gens dangereux qui ont qui sont
sortis de l'arc républicain
quand vous avez des gens qui vont dans
les manifestations pour défiler aux cris
de allahu akbhar ou qui prône le le
burqini dans les piscines c'est qu'il ya
un problème majeur et je pense que
électeurs sondés encensé et iront vers
une opposition qui sera responsable et
républicaine dans votre cas pour vous
aucune consigne de vote non plus dans
les duels ensemble nul vous appelez vos
électeurs à aller à la pêche c'est
vraiment responsable au nom de voilà la
démocratie alors de l'abstention massive
écoutez nous nous les appelons à
l'abstention d'abstention enfin une
abstention ou un vote blanc volontaire
et patriotique parce qu'on a affaire à
des gens qui sont des déçus des
déconstructeurs d'en haut pour les
maquereaux nice avec le mondial y ait
des déconstructeurs d'en bas avec avec
melançon dans les autres cas loup nous
avons laissé le choix
et quand il ya d'autres candidats le
choix à nos électeurs d'aller se porter
éventuellement sur des candidats
extérieurs qui qui aurait
fait la preuve de leur sens patriotique
et on laisse donc la liberté à nous à
nos lecteurs merci beaucoup philippe
olivier c'est vous donner le mot de la
fin béatrice giblin c'est un front
national un rassemblement national qui
s'installe durablement d'autant qu'il va
avoir un groupe 15 au moins députés à
l'assemblée incontestablement la
stratégique avait mis au point philippe
olivier sur la dédiabolisation sur le
fait qu'il fallait arrêter avec le
discours classique on va dire qu avait
mis en place jean marie le pen a
fonctionné et je pense que oui pour le
moment on a une fondation afin
rassemblement national d'ailleurs passé
de front à rassemblement ça voulait déjà
dit un certain temps ça balance c'était
tout un symbole est qui et qui s'étend
et qui s'est ancrée alors maintenant
qu'est ce qui va se passer à gauche et
qu'est ce qui va se passer à droite les
choses vers la partie n'est pas tenable
a terminé il faut absolument prendre
toutes ces estimations en sièges des
instituts de sondages avec beaucoup de
prudence un tout petit mot mais vraiment
vous avez moins de 30 secondes d'arrêt
le bras je pense que la stratégie si le
front national rassemblement national
voulais avoir plus d'élues sa stratégie
ce n'est pas d'accabler mélenchon et la
nuque mais c'est assez curieux la façon
qu'ils ont de faire parce que et c'est
là qu'il pourrait avoir des voix à
prendre et je pense que mélenchon au
contraire a laissé entendre que d'un des
électeurs d'url pourraient voter il a
elle laissé entendre et c'est de bonne
stratégie politique le lien pour vous
quand même des vases communicants entre
ces électorats merci ils n'en veulent
pas aurez compris le le point merci
beaucoup merci d'être venus débattre
merci pour vos éclairages vous rester
avec moi julie aubert parce qu'on va
revenir à présent sur votre itinéraire
disons à l'assemblée je le disais balayé
en quelques minutes ça mérite quelques
explications avec kathia gilder
si on vous invite julien aubert c'est
pour essayer de comprendre
vous avez fait campagne en jouant la
carte du député qu'on reconnaît dans la
rue proche des gens comme l'ont fait
certains de vos collègues sortant marc
lefur en bretagne gilles gosselin sur
les côtes de la manche ou encore
aurélien pradié dans sa circonscription
du lot seulement voilà pour vous ça n'a
pas marché vous avez été sèchement battu
reléguée à la quatrième position avec à
peine plus de 17% des voix victime d'une
concurrence puissante à l'extrême droite
avec le rnd reconquête ça fait réfléchir
vous dit finalement si le travail ne
paie pas s'y être 7e députés de
l'opposition de paie pas faire 48 km par
an pour aller voir les gens ne paient
pas alors voilà je ne sais pas faire
autrement je ne peux pas être un député
qui reste en sirotant un verre de
limonade à la terrasse je sais pas faire
vous avez grandi julien aubert dans le
vaucluse face au mont ventoux vous avez
réussi l'ena en même temps qu emmanuel
macron vous êtes sorti conseiller
référendaire à la cour des comptes
députés élus en 2012 réélu en 2010 est
figurée l'air sur une ligne gaulliste
souverainiste
spécialiste du budget de la sécurité du
nucléaire vous refuser toute
compromission avec la république en
marge des manuels macro pour lui on a
jésus ils marchent sur l'eau emmanuel
macron tout ce qu'il touche on dit que
c'est de l'or vous avez quand même un
habillage qui est incroyable très peu de
critiques de la sueur le président de la
république et donc voilà lille et j'irai
en aidé par un contexte on n'est pas
encore entré sous les dents une analyse
rationnelle de ce qu'est le maquereau
nice lui ses avantages ses inconvénients
julien aubert vous avez perdu votre
siège mais votre parti lui espère
limiter la casse le pire a été évité
pour les nerfs toujours en lice dans 75
circonscriptions
christian jacob voit même le parti comme
la force avec laquelle emmanuel macron
devra composer ça peut être intéressant
pour le pays d'avoir une opposition
utile et c'est sur cette ligne là que
nous avons toujours été nous resterons
force de proposition pour corriger les
textes et je pense que nous serons en
situation de pouvoir le
alors julien aubert vous qui allez
maintenant prendre un peu de recul vous
nous direz quel rôle doit jouer l air à
l'assemblée offensif ou constructif mais
d'abord une question plus personnelle
l'engagement politique at-il encore un
sens quand on est incompris de ses
électeurs
c'est une bonne question
d'abord l'engagement politique c'est pas
forcément un engagement effectif mais
effectivement on parle beaucoup
d'étiquettes et je défends l'idée que au
parlement nelly des hommes et des femmes
par exemple à aucun moment dans les
débats que nous avons eus on s'est
interrogé sur la personnalité des
candidats moi ce que j'ai vu c'est
d'aider bus trn qui travaillent et des
députés rennes qui ne travaillait pas
donc c'est ça qu'on devrait regarder en
priorité donc pour moi l'engagement
politique
d'ensemble et vous êtes très présent il
ya énormément de journalistes qui font
des classements nos députés point fr et
à chaque fois vous faites partie
d'ailleurs dans l'est dans les dix
premiers députés sur les 577 mais cette
reconnaissance là elle existe mais pas
dans les yeux dans les jours c'est à
dire que ces cinq étages avec un nouveau
jeu s'appelait d'élus sakya un
discours dominant qui est de dire oui
les élus sont pas exemplaires ils
travaillent pas ils se moquent de nous
et donc j'ai voulu pendant dix ans
nous voilà je ne mens pas je travaille
j'ai toujours essayé d'être exemplaire à
la fois sur le terrain pour essayer de
restaurer la confiance mais ça veut
attaquer cette perte de confiance et un
populisme ambiant est-ce que s'alourdir
depuis 40 ans et les élus quand ils ont
fait ce qu'ils serap la situation des
fraudes et médias peut-être dans la
situation des français se dégrade depuis
40 ans je suis inquiet pour l'avenir de
ce pays le vote commencera le vote
clientéliste le vote communautariste la
manière dont les gens perçoivent la
démocratie la désaffection l'abstention
la détestation la colère sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya tous ceux ci qui gérait
bouillonne et les français sont furieux
parce que ils voient cette dégradation
ils ont le sentiment que leurs hommes
politiques sont inutiles et vous ne
payez pas une danseuse qui ne dansent
pas disait un de mes amis quand j'étais
jeune auditeur à la cour des comptes
donc j'ai essayé de faire comprendre
pendant ces dix années que les hommes
politiques n'y arriverait pas parce que
nous avons un problème d'indépendance
juridique de souveraineté et que en
réalité il ya une mystification on élit
des gens qui en fait ne peuvent pas agir
parce qu'on leur dit juridiquement vous
ne pouvez pas telles conventions etc
alors attendez vous êtes passé 10 ans à
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui c'est
un échec mais vous savez très bien
l'adage on ne meurt jamais en politique
vous avez sentiment d'avoir été utile
même si in fine et peut être incompris
on change les choses à l'assemblée
franchement sans langue de bois
franchement où il aime dans l'opposition
en jetons les change we will change
comme on en fait une dépense 100 kg
d'énergie pour avoir un gramme
d'efficacité mais je crois que dans la
majorité c'est pas mieux mais oui j'ai
quelques par exemple le délit d' entrave
aux services publics contre l'islamisme
donc fait d'invoquer une idéologie pour
empêcher le bon fonctionnement d'un
service public c'est dans la loi
séparatistes c'est une proposition de
loi que j'avais faite juste après la loi
samuel pâtit gérald darmanin la reprise
sans donner le copyright le nucléaire
par exemple on a beaucoup parlé de la
réorientation de la politique
énergétique du pays pendant dix ans j'ai
travaillé prouvé en tant que rapporteur
spécial du budget de l'écologie j'ai
fait une commission denquête bipartisane
qui à montrer l'inanité de cette
politique et je veux croire que à force
d'avoir des chiffres que personne ne
pouvait contredire tout le monde a
compris qu'à un moment donné ça n'était
pas tenable donc on arrive à faire donc
même avec ce système institutionnel la
vème république
on peut quand même peser quand on est
député et dans l'opposition l'avenir des
républicains vous restez un républicain
oui y'a pas de doute là dessus oui
l'avenir de cette famille politique
comment vous le voyez comment vous le
souhaitez venir aujourd'hui il est
sombre parce que on est sur soixante dix
circonscriptions où je suis combien le
front national chollon 103 60 et 80
députés en fait il ya léman technique
c'est à dire que depuis 2012 nous
perdons du terrain nous n'arriverons pas
enclenché il ya une part de
responsabilité puis à moment donné vous
savez une barde d'élimination c'est à
dire que dans certains territoires si
l'étiquette pèse 6 ou 7% vous commencez
à plus trouver des candidats qui disent
attendait si je prends un risque
financier trop important c'est ça le
risque qui est derrière et donc il
faudrait vraiment un changement c'est ce
que j'avais dit changer tout du sol au
plafond pour pour que l'étiquette attire
parce que moi je dis c'est quand j'étais
sur le terrain les gens misez vous vous
êtes formidables mais moi je voterais
jamais républicain parce que les
républiques as et puis remonter sur 10
ou 15 ans donc ça c'est un vrai un vrai
problème si vous avez côtoyé emmanuel
macron sur les bancs de l'ena vous avez
même fait un livre là-dessus dans
lesquelles vous l'appelez le faux
prophète et vous le tutoyer on a
beaucoup dit qu emmanuel macron avait
fracturé peut-être pas tuer la droite
mais largement fracturée vous pensez que
le maquereau nisme survivra à emmanuel
macron puisque c'est son dernier mandat
en tout cas pour les sacs réutilisables
dont je pense mais je peux me tromper et
visiblement depuis le début c'est plutôt
lui qui a raison parce que c'est lui qui
a été réélu président de la république
et moi qui était battu comme député met
donc chacun prend ses engrais clivage
droite gauche va renaître au moins 8 en
train de renaître et dellal dany prenez
l'exemple du pc quoi c'est la
renaissance de la gauche parce qu'en
fait ce qu'il a fait c'est qu'il a voulu
manger la droite donc il est parti très
à droite et il a ressuscité une extrême
gauche de la même manière que nicolas
sarkozy avait voulu manger la gauche et
il avait ressuscité d'extrême droite
donc en fait ce qui s'est passé avec
emmanuel macron jean luc mélenchon c'est
ce qui s'était passé nicolas sarkozy
marine le pen est en réalité la macro ni
ne le sait pas mais elle est déjà
quasiment un mort vivant pourquoi parce
qu'il ya plus d'élan parce qu'on ne sait
plus très bien si soit gauche sur la
droite en 2012 2017 c'était je dirais
une renaissance avec des jeunes visages
il y avait quand même une formule j'ai
été marqué quand je suis revenu au
parlement de voir cet enthousiasme il ya
un bouillonnement démocratique la sepa
bouillonnement démocratique c'est les
opportunistes associer tous les gens du
vieux monde qui se réunissent en disant
nous sommes cernés et on va mettre sous
le tapis tout ce qui nous sépare pour
garder les postes la politique c'est
fini pour vous pas
mais ce que vous allez faire travailler
je rejoins de mon corps d'origine quand
des corrélats après en tant que citoyen
j'ai droit à voir un engagement
politique j'ai un mouvement qui
s'appelle osé la france qui est
d'ailleurs beaucoup grossi suite à la
défaite présidentielle et je vais donc
faire vivre le débat d'idées oui
toujours à quoi on pense la journée
comme ça où on passe à l'assemblée vous
nous avez confié avant avant d'entrer en
studio pour au fond faire ses cartons
avant que les nouveaux arrivent on
essaye de ne pas les croiser ses
déficits oui j'avais beaucoup réfléchi
ça fait dix ans que je réfléchissais à
ce moment donc je m'étais préparé
psychologiquement on n'a pas envie de
croiser c'est d'abord parce que on
appartient déjà plus si vous voulez on
est on est en train de partir donc le
demain appartient aux conquérants vous
vous faites partie des vaincus donc vous
devez céder la place et normal c'est la
loi de la démocratie ce qui durera près
ces voix-là sur les aspects techniques
parce que vous devez couper en fait on
vous demande de couper en quelques jours
dix ans de travail donc c'est évidemment
il ya plein de connexion administrative
personnel humaine et ça c'est ça c'est
le plus dur merci beaucoup merci merci
pour ces mots julien aubert allez vous
rester avec moi c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos a franchi pour leur
parti-pris vous allez voir ils vont vous
interpeller ce soir elle demande un
gamma pour son carnet de campagne
quotidien sur des décisions hâtives
brandon noir est et ses archives ce soir
des ministres battus aux législatives
une vieille histoire et richard berry
qui va nous parler de la tournée des
manuels mac ou en ont marre en roumanie
ou en moldavie et en moldavie kiev ou
pas qui est natif de postionne nos a
franchi les voici bonsoir à vous trois
ans sont ravis de vous accueillir alsa
vous nous parler ce soir de la première
ministre elisabeth bornes interpellé sur
le terrain alors qu'elle faisait
campagne dans sa circonscription sur la
sphère damien abad oui sur les dernières
révélations de mediapart le journal en
ligne a publié hier le témoignage d'une
femme est là qu celui qui est
aujourd'hui ministre des solidarités de
tentative de viol en 2010 le papier fait
aussi état de comportements inappropriés
déplacer alors cet article on le sait il
fait suite à des premières révélations
c'était le 20 mai dernier le lendemain
de la nomination de damien abad au
gouvernement deux familles ils
dénonçaient des faits de viol une seule
à porter plainte une plainte classée
sans suite damien abad lui a toujours
nié il parle d'allégations et les réfute
catégorique elisabeth board en campagne
dans sa circonscription du calvados a dû
réagir oui puisqu'elle a été interpellé
par une femme alors selon matignon c'est
est une militante de la nuque proche de
nos égos char c'est son adversaire dans
la circonscription l'équipe de nos égos
sharks on a contacté dément tout coup
monté ça c'est sur la forme sur le fond
il ya eu un échange écoutez
je dis vraiment aux femmes et je le dis
en tant que premier ministre et en tant
que femme
je nous invite à déposer plainte
parce que c'est important que la justice
puisse dire l'effet qu'un homme utilise
son staff nature d'homme de pouvoir pour
avoir des faveurs ça vous dérange pas
bien sûr que ça me dérange les vans
wheels encore l'attendait mais bien
l'attendait madame je sais pas moi qui
ai moi je suis pas juge vous savez la
première ministre reste donc pour
l'instant sur la ligne fixée par le
gouvernement elle renvoie vers la
justice lat optimaux de réaction allait
dessus damien abad que vous connaissez
évidemment très bien
je pense qu'il ya d'un côté la justice
et puis de l'autre côté il ya la
responsabilité politique c'est au
gouvernement de se demander s'il peut
vivre s'il peut administrer le pays avec
un ministre qui régulièrement fait
l'objet de ce que vous en pensez mais
moi je ne suis pas le jeu ne suis pas
son prix
je pense qu'il commence à y avoir
suffisamment si vous voulez d'affaires
pour que ça pour qu'effectivement ça
pose porte un discrédit mais je vous
ferai remarquer que dans le même temps
damien abad réalise un excellent score
preuve que vers
allons regarder que le peuple qui vote
lui ne pondère peut-être pas les
éléments donnés manière est là on
poursuit il ya un autre premier ministre
alors c'est l'ancien premier ministre
lui qui est très très demandé dans cette
campagne c'est edouard philippe c'est
une vraie tournée du maire du havre
c'est même à se demander s'il n'a pas le
don d'ubiquité
d'ubiquité pardon regarder sur le compte
twitter de son parti horizon à rien
qu'aujourd'hui il est allé soutenir
trois candidats paris pierre yves
bournazel clément bonne sylvain maillard
une candidate dans les hauts-de-seine
aurélie thakil 1 ce soir il est à
tonnerre dans l'yonne avec son ami avec
qui s'est réconcilié françois bayrou et
hier vous l'avez vu dans le sujet 2
marion becker il était à beauvais en
campagne en campagne ça veut dire
serrage de mains et celles fille il se
démultiplie pourquoi c'est simple et
bien parce que tout le monde le veut
nous confia proches edouard philippe à
fond dans la campagne
pourtant les mauvaises langues disent eh
bien qu edward fils qu'il souhaiterait
plutôt une majorité un peu étriqué comme
ça son groupe horizon pourrait jouer un
rôle de pivot mais ça ce sont des
élucubrations de journalisme est rien
mais coûte edouard philippe ne fait pas
campagne pour mon bon j'ai fait campagne
pour la majorité ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que on puisse donner au pays une
majorité stable et solide et c'est la
seule chose qui m'intéresse parce que je
pense que c'est indispensable dans la
période périlleuse
mais je sais que les commentateurs
politiques adorent conjecturer sur les
équilibres respectifs mais pour moi
pardon de vous lire et j'espère que vous
ne m'en voudrez pas tout ça c'est de la
toute petite politique une petite
réaction quand même et d'horribles lui
aussi vous le connaissez très bien c'est
un ancien républicain
et c'est bien joué quand même valérie
pécresse fait 4 % il semblait inutile il
devient le pivot larbitre dans cette
dans cette grande coalition du service
offert beaucoup de pivot pour une
majorité qui n'est pas encore né un tout
le monde le parti charnière bon ça me
fait penser à la ivème république
que le président la pluie n'est pas une
majorité pléthorique parce qu'un
parlement qui est écrasé par 400 députés
très honnêtement ça ça ça allège un peu
l'intérêt de l'activité parlementaire on
verra ça évidemment dimanche prochain
19h30 sur lcp on sera évidemment
présente avec avec lda abandonne alors
c'est une des histoires on va ouvrir les
cartons d'archivés parce que des
ministres en campagne qu'ils y subissent
la règle la règle elle existe depuis
longtemps un bandeau noir est ceo vous
êtes élu vous restez vous n'êtes pas élu
vous portez et il ya pas mal de deux
ministres en difficulté amélie de
montchanin clément bonne stanislas
guérini notamment une tradition qui
existe depuis 1967 avec le général de
gaulle cette année là c'est la première
fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république que des ministres en fonction
candidats aux législatives
perdre une circonscription alors ils
sont quatre quatre ministres qui restent
sur le carreau le premier c'est jean
charbonnel il est secrétaire d'état aux
affaires étrangères il est battu au
second tour en corrèze et démissionne la
deuxième défaite c'est alexandre
sanguinetti il est député sortant
ministre des anciens combattants il est
battu sur le fil
49% second tour ce qui l'obligent à
démissionner sauf que de gaulle ne veut
pas sacrifier tous ses ministres
notamment les plus connus alors il va
faire deux exceptions la première c'est
la défaite surprise de maurice couve de
murville le l'indéboulonnable ministre
des affaires étrangères qui est en place
depuis dix ans il est battu au second
tour avec 49% des suffrages mais il
conserve son portefeuille et un an plus
tard il devient même le dernier premier
ministre du général de gaulle la seconde
est exception c'est en 1967 toujours les
cas messmer c'est une défaite surprise
qui surprend toute la presse et toutes
opinions publiques il est nettement
nettement battu au second tour il
obtient 47 6% des suffrages mais il
conserve son ministère et il deviendra
même le premier ministre de georges
pompidou cinq ans plus tard en 1972
toutefois si 1988 c'est une figure de la
société civile qui fait les frais des
législatives bahi k il caracole déjà en
tête des personnalités préférées des
français depuis qu'il a fondé et
médecins du monde et médecins sans
frontières c'est bernard kouchner qui
vient tout juste d'être nommé secrétaire
d'état chargé de l'insertion
professionnelle de chargé de l'insertion
sociale pardon dans le gouvernement
rocard alors il est parachuté dans le
nord par le parti socialiste sauf que
là-bas kouchner n'est pas aussi
populaire qui ne le pense et pour
répondre aux critiques des locaux il a
une défense bien à lui écoutez le donc
une importance moi vous savez de temps
en temps j'ai des surprises mais je
crois pas beaucoup à la bonne nature de
l'homme ce n'est pas mon problème vous
reviendrez
je reviendrai voir mes amis en tout cas
attendons la normalement devrait le
savoir mais dans quelques temps double
sens oui bien sûr je reviendrai en tout
cas bernard kouchner assume totalement
son parachutage écouter ce qu'ils
disaient quelques jours plus tôt on m'a
proposé le nord et j'ai considéré que
non j'avais des attaches dans des tas
d'endroits mais là j'étais en difficulté
vous trouvez que c'est quelque chose de
sain enfin comme ça ça dépend comment on
atterrit alors moi j'ai très bien
atterri j'aurais pu aller dans un
département du midi les choses sont plus
riantes peut-être moi j'ai choisi
d'aller avec ces gens qui se battent
pour retrouver non seulement un emploi
mais une dignité un résultat quand le
parachute et mal accroché on s'écrase on
se retrouve avec % au premier tour la
boussole est déréglée kouchner perd le
nord et démissionne 88 à une autre
défaite importante pour un membre du
gouvernement non cette fois ci ce n'est
pas un parachutage puisque c'est une
défaite locale une présence très
importante notamment à strasbourg c'est
catherine trautmann la future maire de
la ville elle vient d'être nommée
secrétaire d'état aux personnes âgées
aux handicapés et la ministre elle est
novice en politique à ce moment là elle
a du mal à digérer sa défaite
je suis un petit peu enfin
si vous voulez pas déçu mais peut-être
touché parce que j'ai quand même un peu
le sentiment d'une injustice dans la
mesure où effectivement j'étais le
ministre nous moins mal battue de ce
gouvernement la très grosse surprise on
s'en souvient en tout cas je m'en
souviens personnellement c'est 2007
surprise évidemment cela vient tout
juste d'être nommé numéro deux du
gouvernement ministre d'état ministre de
l'ecologie et il est battu en gironde de
justesse alors qu'il domine très
largement le premier tour par michèle
delaunay alors alain juppé forcément au
lendemain de sa défaite lorsqu'il doit
inaugurer le salon des vins on sent la
nervosité à bordeaux
très très bonne
c'est parce qu'ils bichonnent le soir
c'est encore pire
alain juppé démissionne après cette
défaite mais ça n'empêchera pas trois
ans plus tard de retrouver un nouveau
pote pour tous on se souvient de la
défense on s'en souvient très bien on
verra d'ailleurs un combien de ministres
seront sur le caron pas crise politique
possible ou simplement mauvais signal
pour un gouvernement nous nous vu signol
mais en tout cas je note que plus on
perd les élections plus autre chose
devenir premier ministre c'est très
grands voiliers tout ça c'est raisonner
alors fait vivre je me suis accroché moi
aussi j'ai découvert ça va vous
intéresser on va parler à présent avec
richard berner de de ce suspense
entretenu par le président de la
république ira-t-il ou non à kiev au
fond vous nous dites ce soir dans votre
chronique s'il même s'il y va c'est un
peu tard selon-vous rsa alors
effectivement vous savez il ya la
politique d'un côté il y à la diplomatie
alors l'impression jusque là c'est
qu'ils manuel macron il n'a pas pu ou il
n'a pas su où il n'a pas voulu choisir
entre les deux alors on sait
l'importance que le chef de l'état
français attachent depuis le début du
conflit en ukraine au maintien d'un
canal de discussion avec vladimir
poutine on a aussi en tête toute la
controverse suscitée par ses propos
mettant en garde contre une possible
humiliation la russie vous me direz que
là d'un point de vue diplomatique c'est
rationnel c'est pragmatique ça peut même
être logique d'ailleurs le chancelier
allemand olaf schulze et le président du
conseil italien mario draghi sont sur la
même ligne ils ne sont pas encore allés
à kiev on murmure que peut-être les
trois pour aller ensemble effectivement
alors le problème c'est que d'autres ont
fait de la politique
ceux qui ont fait de la politique c'est
les premiers ministres polonais
slovaques tchèques britannique portugais
alors en tête il y a évidemment le
va-t-en-guerre boris johnson qui lui il
est très présent sur ce dossier
ukrainien il est vrai qu'il a des choses
à se faire pardonner au royaume uni mais
il y est aussi au nom de son grand allié
américain alors la difficulté de cette
question entre politiques ou diplomatie
c'est que cette distinction est bien
elle ne passe pas on pourrait presque
dire que sur l'ukraine le en même temps
ça ne peut pas marcher parce que si l'on
se tourne vers les capitales européennes
très franchement elles ne comprennent
pas pourquoi emmanuel macron président
en exercice de l'union européenne est
toujours pas aller à kiev d'autant que
en n'y allant pas il laisse comme je les
dis la place à d'autres y compris à
ursula von der leyen la présidente de la
commission européenne qu'il y est allé à
de reflets et qui en quelque sorte hors
un peu le bras des pays de l'union
européenne quant à la demande d'adhésion
de l'ukraine compte qu'il devrait
examiner les 23 et 24 juin à bruxelles
ne pas y aller au fond c'est alimenter
le doute alors ça doute sera-t-il lever
enfin il sera évidemment le v6 il décide
d'y aller en fait semaine eh bien
écoutez c'est pas sûr du tout même si
elles macro y va maintenant avec
éventuellement le chancelier scholl's et
avec mario draghi il est probable que le
doute va rester pour une raison très
simple vous savez on le dit toujours et
on le vit chacun avec nos amis quand on
est en difficulté on voit ce qu'ils
réagissent tout de suite ceux qui sont à
vos côtés tout de suite et bien les
ukrainiens ils ont quand même vu qu
emmanuel macron n'a pas été parmi les
premiers à venir vous ajoutez à ça toute
la controverse autour de la nation les
médiations mais au cias mais aussi le
poids économique des entreprises il faut
bien le dire française allemande et
italienne en russie bref même si
emmanuel macron se décide à y aller il
est fort probable que les ukrainiens lui
gros merci mais avec quand même quelques
arrière-pensées merci beaucoup mercier
réservé les merci à vous les aubert non
c'est pour cette franchise c'est assez
rare pour être soulignée merci à vous
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis tout de suite votre
soirée documentaire avec jean pierre
gratien ce soir loin devant un film sur
l'accueil des réfugiés dans notre pays
signent un look dure elle très belle
soirée sur lcp à demain
[Musique]